alors il va ni biélorussie liban
emmanuel macron est sur tous les fronts
alors qu'est-ce que les dernières prises
de parole du président à l'international
révèle qu'elle est sa stature sur la
scène mondiale qu'elle voit le chef de
l'état ont tenté de donner à la france
dans le monde
c'est l'objet de notre décryptage et
pour en parler nous sommes avec alexis
poulain éditorialistes bonsoir à vos
côtés françois el bacha économiste et
fondateur de libnanews bonsoir et nous a
rejoint également claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales
rebond se croire claude blanche maison
alors messieurs on a on a donc entendu
un ces dernières heures les mots engagés
du président français sur la scène
internationale tout d'abord à propos du
liban où il a dit avoir honte pour et
les dirigeants libanais concernant le
dossier biélorussie l'a affirmé il est
clair que loukachenko doit partir alors
claude blanche maison je me tourne vers
vous emmanuel macron comme médiateur
c'est aussi la volonté de l'opposante
bébé la rustique anoska ya une rencontre
est prévue demain entre les deux
emmanuel macron a déjà tranché lui le
président biélorusse lukashenko doit
partir dans ce contexte le terme
médiateur est il approprié finalement
alors évidemment c'est très difficile
d'abord pourra dire que emmanuel macron
entrepris de rendre visite à tous les
pays membres de l'union européenne qu'il
soit grand ou petit et que d'ailleurs il
n'ya pas de petits pays dans l'union
européenne puisque chacun a une voix au
conseil européen et peut s'opposer à une
décision chacun a un droit de veto
alors il se trouve que là il va
rencontrer l'opposante biélorusse
puisque c'est un pays voisin
d'ailleurs voisin de la biélorussie mais
aussi voisin de kaliningrad est une
enclave russe à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne
donc il va évoquer les problèmes de
sécurité avec les autorités de la
lituanie de la lettonie
et puis il va écouter ce que madame
cette lan a dit canada a à lui dire ce
qu'il a à lui dire demain matin et il
est probable qu'on ait fait elle va
réitérer ce qu'elle a dit hier au
journal du dimanche à savoir une demande
qu'ils participent à une médiation sous
une forme ou sous une autre médiation ou
ou facilitation pour trouver une
solution
elle même dit qu'il doit user de ses
bonnes relations avec monsieur poutine
puisque l'opposition a le cas de shinko
pour le moment n'a à aucun moment émis
des opinions anti russe lit la russie et
notre voisine et nous voulons avoir de
bons rapports avec la russie
donc c'est une situation tout à fait
particulière et très clairement affirmée
alors je pense que personne ne peut être
le médiateur sans doute monsieur macron
proposera t-il à madame dykan of gaia
d'en parler bien sûr aux autres
dirigeants européens puisqu'il y à jeudi
et vendredi un conseil européen à
bruxelles il en parlera certainement
avant même cela madame angela merkel et
pour voir dans quelle mesure
l'union européenne peut aider à trouver
une solution il en portera certainement
aussi au téléphone avec vladimir poutine
comme il l'a déjà fait je noterai aussi
que madame chicanos callas considère que
des sanctions économiques ne sont pas
appropriés parce que dans le fond ça se
retournerait contre la population
devienne russie et que dans cette
affaire il s'agit de défendre la
population de biélorussie et de voir
comment en effet faire en sorte que le
dictateur biélorusse dernier dictateur
en europe finissent par céder la place à
un régime plus démocratique en tout cas
qui correspondent aux besoins du moment
en biélorussie alors alexis poulain
pendant ce temps il ya un contexte de
crise sanitaire et économique qui est
lourd en france
est ce que vous comprenez de sept
volumes volonté du président français de
vouloir endosser le rôle de médiateur à
l'international c'est un peu facile pour
emmanuel macron aujourd'hui ce qu'il
fait c'est qu'il est présent
effectivement surtout
les fronts mais certainement pas à
domicile on a l'impression qu'il préfère
parler du liban plutôt que de parler de
son bilan
parce que aujourd'hui en france les
français eux parlent de la crise du
grenat virus les commerçants à marseille
mais ailleurs ont peur d'un nouveau
confinement de la fermeture de leur
commerce de manière totalement
disproportionnées par rapport à la crise
sanitaire que nous vivons or emmanuel
macron a décidé de sensibiliser de la
scène nationale et d'exister à
l'international parce que c'est là qu'il
va pouvoir se refaire une stature de
présidentiable
pour 2022 et évidemment c'est
extrêmement facile ça lui permet
d'échapper à la critique puisque là sur
la scène internationale il est respecté
en tant que président d'un pays qui est
la france est encore un pays respecté
dans les relations internationales
la preuve en est madame chicanos kaya
qui lui demande d'être médiateur légal
de la russie dans la crise biélorusse le
liban là par contre c'est un peu plus
compliqué on voit bien que la parole des
malades macron n'a pas été du tout
respecté ou prise en compte par les
parties en présence au liban qui décide
de faire comme à l'habitude et c'est à
dire de s'arranger entre eux à la façon
d'avancer macron n'a aucun mandat sur le
liban il faudrait peut-être un mandat
international d'autre chose mais la
france ne pèse pas comme il était le cas
avant on n'est plus dans un monde
colonial de protectorat ou autre il
faudrait qu'ils veulent macro se met à
jour donc pour lui c'est tout bénéfice
en fait de manière politique pour se
réinventer refaire une image se
reprendre un peu de la hauteur et c'est
ce que fait me les maquereaux
aujourd'hui françois élevage alexis
poulain parlait du liban à l'instant de
cette prise de parole adressée aux
dirigeants libanais avec des mots durs
vous propose de regarder et puis on vous
entend après françois el bacha les
forces politiques libanaises leurs
dirigeants
les dirigeants des institutions
libanaises n'ont pas souhaité clairement
résolument explicitement n'ont pas
souhaité respecter l'engagement pris
devant la france et la communauté
internationale ils ont décidé
et je suis contraint d'en faire le
constat cruel pour nous tous un mois
plus tard ils ont décidé de trahir cet
engagement pris alors françois el bacha
comment cette prise de parole at elle
été reçue par la population est ce que
c'est ce que souhaitait entendre les
libanais au fond les libanais ils sont
fatigués des partis politiques donc oui
plus on fait la pression sur les partis
politiques à +6 apprécié le problème
aujourd'hui est qu'on a besoin
le problème de base c'est qu'on a un
dysfonctionnement structurel au liban le
liban ne peut pas fonctionner depuis les
accords de taef sans ingérence étrangère
tout simplement il faut des parents à
chaque fois et on a eu on est le parrain
américain on a le parrain iranien on à
la turquie de rentrer dans le jeu et on
espère une ingérence bienveillante qui
puisse changer le système
parce qu'on ne peut pas changer le
système par nous-mêmes libanais n'ont
pas les moyens de changer le système par
eux-mêmes tout simplement à cause de
toutes ces ingérences
donc effectivement le d'un point de vue
beaucoup de gens sont assez favorables à
cette ingérence la 6è les bienveillantes
alexis poulain effectivement ce mot
ingérence on l'a entendu aussi en france
avec des réactions nombreuses notamment
sur les réseaux sociaux
et puis beaucoup se sont en parallèle
interrogé sur la vivacité du président
français tout en dotant son silence sur
les dossiers français ça vous a étonné
aussi rallye cool un nom c'est
effectivement tout le monde a bien vu
que quand emmanuel macron parler du
liban c'était un peu comme dans ce film
de pagnol
la femme du boulanger ou le boulanger
s'adresse à la chatte qui est partie
pour finalement s'adresser à sa femme
donc emmanuel macron parler du liban
pour parler de la france à ceux qui
voulaient bloquer la situation à ceux
qui ne voulaient pas d'unité nationale
on sentait très bien que derrière cette
situation libanaise
il avait en écho sa situation
personnelle et l'état français
donc ça c'était un peu déplacé par
rapport à la crise libanaise et puis
un fait est que emmanuel macron a sans
doute présumé de ses forces et de sa
stature pour aller directement au liban
et s'imposer comme médiateur
quel est son mandat quel est aujourd'hui
le mandat international qui permettrait
de mettre tout le monde autour de la
table et de réunir bien il ya un
président au liban michel aoun qui doit
être trouvée un nouveau premier ministre
puisqu'il ya un premier ministre
démissionnaire et remettre les partis
autour de la table ou bien refaire des
élections revoir une chose mais quel est
le rôle du président français dans cette
affaire là à part de dire que oui la
france est bien tend la main au peuple
libanais essaye de faire des choses et
même macron là encore une fois fait un
peu comme il a l'habitude c'est à dire
qu'il se lance dans des aventures sans
avoir les moyens finalement de voir là
où ça emmène tout un pays tout une
diplomatie et ça c'est extrêmement
dangereuse set extrêmement volatile et
j'espère que dans la sphère de leca
biélorusse on va pas se retrouver dans
une même impasse ce n'est pas à
souhaiter
sachant que emma le maquereau bien sûr
garde le dialogue ouvert avec avec la
russie ça c'est extrêmement important
dans ce cas là pour le liban c'est autre
chose on a vu le hesbollah la façon dont
il a admonesté georges malbrunot qui
avait soi disant sorti des informations
qu'il n'aurait pas dû excusez moi mais
un journaliste re son métier c'est de
sortir des informations pour que les
gens soient informés
il n'a pas s'arrêter là où commence la
diplomatie ou l'intérêt du chef de
l'état donc une leçon apprise
espérons que celle-ci aura porté ses
fruits dans les autres affaires
internationales dans lesquels emmanuel
macron va s'impliquer plus blanches
saison on vous a vu sourire quand alexis
poulain d'isaac emmanuel macron vous
l'êtes aussi à parler à la france quand
il s'exprimait devant le peuple libanais
est ce que effectivement
diplomatiquement il peut y avoir des
messages subliminaux finalement
je crois que emmanuel macron a décidé
d'abandonner le langage diplomatique
feutray pour dire carrément tout ce que
beaucoup de gens pensent tout bas
et c'est le cas dans les affaires
libanaises c'est ce que on l'a dit
d'ailleurs aussi tout à l'heure alors
bien sûr ça peut choquer parce qu'après
tout le liban à un gouvernement on peut
penser ce qu'on veut de ce gouvernement
mais c'est le gouvernement du liban et
il est probable que ce gouvernement et
les élites il va l'être ont pas été très
heureuse entendre qu'elles ont entendu
hier mais cela dit tactiquement macron
en faisant cela a pris une posture qui
sur la scène internationale est une
posture intéressante c'est à dire qu'il
a la main sur les flux des ide a dit
très clairement en réalité aux hauts
dirigeants libanais je m'opposerai à
l'aide de l'union européenne je
m'opposerai à l'aide internationale
à l'aide du fmi si vous continuez comme
ça donc les dirigeants sont au pied du
mur
apparemment ils sont assez intéressés
par ces flux financiers
et bien il y aura pas de flux financiers
d'elle tant pis si le régime libanais
continue comme il l'a fait auparavant
et s'il ya un risque de détournement de
cette aide internationale
alors effectivement si le gouvernement
libanais acceptent qu'il y ait à une
organisation de l'onu des ong qui
garantissent que ces fonds de répondre
ne pourront pas détournés et qu'ils
iront effectivement à l'éducation de la
population à la santé de la population à
la construction des infrastructures
il pourra y avoir une année c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs qu'il a qui l'a répété
qu'il souhaitait réunir les bailleurs de
fonds avant la fin du mois d'octobre
mais il a la main sur le robinet de
l'aide françois el bacha on se souvient
emmanuel macron avait lancé un ultimatum
aux dirigeants libanais pour qu'il forme
un gouvernement rapidement ils ne l'ont
pas fait comment est ce que les
dirigeants libanais perçoivent le
président français aujourd'hui comme ati
précédemment monsieur même sont les les
dirigeants libanais sont très intéressés
par led économes look
donc et ils ont été pendant longtemps
des bénéficiaires par exemple des
programmes européens de gestion des
ordures qui ont coûté 160 5 millions de
dollars financés par l'europe et 50% de
ces sommes ont été surfacturés et les
bénéficiaires sont des sociétés
appartenant à des hommes politiques
ça c'est un fait fermer cette vanne et
ben c'est un peu les asphyxier aussi
mais ils ont transféré cet argent à
l'étranger
c'est là c'est pas des dirigeants
politiques en fin de course est dédiée
ce et des chefs d'entreprise qui ont
détourné tout un système économique mise
en place et toute une masse tout un
système mafieux mise en place du temps
de la syrie à leurs propres bénéfices
pendant la syrie s'est retirée du liban
c'est très simple et maintenant qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui s'intéresse de nouveau au
liban
en même temps ils sont intéressés il ya
le il ya la carotte et en même temps il
ya le bâton ils n'auront pas accès à
cette aide
tout simplement alors alex ivoula on
vous a entendu assez critique sur la
posture à l'international du chef de
l'état vous en attendez quoi vous
aujourd'hui du du président emmanuel
macron sur cette posture selon vous
qu'il devrait avoir
aujourd'hui à l'international notamment
sur le dossier libanais et le dossier
biélorusse sur le dossier libanais la
france ne peut pas y aller seul en
réalité c'est quel est le mandat
international
aujourd'hui qui va remettre des
responsables politiques autour de la
table et qui va faire que le peuple
libanais ne va pas être encore une fois
victime des intérêts privés de quelques
partis qui effectivement vont capter les
richesses sur les autres dossiers
internationaux j'espère qu'il y aura de
la prudence parce que ce qu'on voit avec
emmanuel macron souvent c'est beaucoup
d' aventure
ces quelques coups de poker et
malheureusement aujourd'hui la france
n'a pas forcément les moyens de ses
ambitions il faut voir que dans
certaines crises il faudrait peut-être
être un peu plus réaliste et s'appuyer
sur des alliés et ne pas avoir une
position forcément atlantiste ou autres
parce que aujourd'hui l'union européenne
un problème à résoudre deux disons
d'abord la crise migratoire aujourd'hui
clairement non résolus et puis la crise
sanitaire celle du comité
on voit bien qu'un peu partout dans les
pays européens france allemagne belgique
et autres vient cette crise n'est
certainement pas résolu donc vouloir
ouvrir de nouveaux fronts aujourd'hui à
l'international en pensant que nous
sommes en position de force
c'est pour moi une grave erreur qui
pourrait coûter cher notamment à la
france dans les années à venir après une
reine macron parce qu'il y aura un après
claude blanchou maison est ce que cette
posture pourrait coûter cher à la france
dans les années à venir comme le
souligne à l'instant alexis poulain
selon vous je crois que tout chef de
l'état français quel qu'il soit et
chacun avec sa femme anne hier et est
préoccupé naturellement par ce qui se
passe dans les pays voisins par la paix
et la sécurité
et pour ça bon on est d'accord on n'est
pas d'accord mais à l'union européenne
et au delà de l'union européenne
il est préoccupé par ce qui se passe
dans les pays environnants et ce qui se
passe en méditerranée fait partie de cet
environnement
alors c'est vrai que il est légitime que
un chef d'état français se préoccupe de
la paix de la stabilité en biélorussie
or elle n'est plus assurée aujourd'hui
avec un président contesté comme les
monsieur loukachenko par conséquent il
est il doit en effet avec en et les
autres partenaires européens avec le
chef de l'état russe avec la dîmière
poutine se préoccuper des lavaur est un
processus de transition en biélorussie
et de la même manière d'élaborer un
processus de transition en au liban
parce que la situation actuelle
d'abord le peuple libanais souffrent
puisque est un appauvrissement
considérable du peuple libanais mais
c'est une situation potentiellement
explosive est très dangereuse pour la
stabilité de la région
donc je crois que encore une fois quel
que soit les présidents futur de la
france ils auront une préoccupation du
même du même style du même genre le mot
de la fin pour conclure françois el
bacha qu'est ce que vous attendez du
président français qu'est ce que le
liban en tout cas attendue du président
français
à court et moyen terme à court terme une
aide les réserves monétaires qui servent
à subventionner les produits de première
nécessité seront épuisées d'ici un an et
demi maintenant ça veut dire que d'ici
un an et demi on aura ou une
paupérisation accélérée parce qu'on doit
avoir une dévaluation de facto plus
important de la libanaise ou des
troubles sociaux économiques
considérables donc emmanuel macron là
dessus a raison sur son inventaire de la
situation
ça c'est un moyen terme d'un point de
vue strictement économique quand il a
parlé des banques et du système bancaire
en particulier il a eu raison
c'est quelque chose que que certains
cercles disait depuis longtemps il y a
les partis ne sont pas seulement des
partis politiques ce sont des personnes
qui sont proches des milieux d'affaires
et qui ont détourné d'énormes sommes à
partir de ces de la dette à partir tout
simplement
donc s'il ya une pression internationale
une ingérence bienveillante
on aura le liban a plus à gagner qu'à
perdre tout simplement
on a beau eu beaucoup d' ingérence qui
ont étaient nocives les ingérences
américaines les ingérences des agences
iraniennes et ainsi de suite
hélas si on a une ingérence positive la
france a aussi à y gagner parce qu'il ya
des histoires d'hydrocarbures au large
des côtes mais aussi à 25 millions de
migrants syriens présents au liban qui
peuvent ensuite déferlé sur l'europe
donc ça peut être du donnant donnant
tort on peut avoir une ingérence positif
sur le liban tout simplement un grand
merci à tous les trois d'avoir répondu à
nos questions merci à vous françois el
bacha je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste fondateur de libnanews merci
avant claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales
merci à vous alexis poulain je rappelle
que vous êtes éditorialistes